welcome to a quick Business Monitor demo
I'm about to login to our out-of-the-box
framework called business space and then
we'll look at dashboard capabilities
they have several widgets on the
dashboard I have three KPI widgets that
you'll see and then an instance widget
and then an alert widget our KPIs are
real time values they have color coded
ranges of operation they have target
values and then they have actuals
updated potentially every few seconds
the ranges can just be a visual
reference or they can drive alerts based
on the values that ranges that we've
defined in the instance view we're
looking at detailed data about processes
claimed loans orders transactions that
we're monitoring and then the alerts are
based on either KPIs or individual
instances business situations that have
been defined that we need to know about
these can send emails they can have
detailed data it can kick off other
services or they can just appear on the
dashboard the data that we have
available in the instance view depends
on what we're monitoring of course but
the user can determine what subset of
that they need to see for their role so
they can sort and search any of these
columns dynamically and then save those
if needed for their own views reports
are continuously being updated users can
create new reports on the fly at any
time they can be defined or they can
have some drill down capabilities I'm
going to show you a couple of drill down
options here we're going to look at
drilling down by department those
departments that have placed orders for
these products and our little sample
here here's a crosstab view as well as
the column view hold the cursor over the
column to see the actual value
and they'll just refresh the widget to
go back up to the highest level view and
then we'll drill down by time first
we'll start with a view of all the
orders in the years that we have and
these drill downs can be configured to
be automatic at different levels
now I'm drilling in two months here
we'll see all the orders placed in a
particular month and reflect the
department that has placed the orders
now we're drilling back up we'll drill
up one more time is to show you that
capability is there lots of different
options on how to present the data to an
end-user different chart types
formatting choices that you have now I'm
going to take this example and in
another type of report drill down and
filter a detailed list of instances
based on the column of report data so
I'll click on pens here and say show me
the instances of those types of orders
and the list is instantly filtered for
me some other examples here of report
types here's a heatmap
these are based on Cognos visualizations
that are available and then another type
of bar chart if you want to get into
more detailed formatting options then
the Cognos tools are included and
available if you want to go to that
depth we've been looking at real time
KPIs these are the historical views of
those same KPIs this is order amount
total being tracked over time we see
where it crosses the target value that
we had set we see the color coding of
the ranges mirrors that that was said
earlier and I'm selecting time ranges
that I want to view these can be set by
default or you can change them on the
fly to look at a particular period of
interest
you'll see the range names and the
values show up here to get to the
boundary of the lair or the range that
has been defined you can change the
number of sampling points that I'm
showing on the display at any time an
entirely new dashboard view for a
different user
so they've selected a different set of
widgets to view for their role and yet
another example so the business user has
lots of power to determine what they see
in a different example I'm monitoring a
BPM process here this one has to do with
hiring so I'm looking at KPIs for the
cost of performing the process steps and
then transitioning to measurements about
the time how long the steps take to
execute so these are in minutes and then
the outcome of the process how many
candidates were approved how many we had
to go for second-level approval how many
were rejected and so on and of course
we're collecting report data on all this
so now we're slicing and dicing the data
about those hiring processes that we've
run by department by title by hiring
manager by pay level by location the
duration by pay level lots of different
options here another dashboard page
shows us a picture of the process and
some KPIs about the steps that are
running cost wait time execution time
and so on
now we've overlaid real time process
data on a map and these images can be of
anything and then the real time data
gets overlaid on that another example
file transfer this data is coming from
Sterling connect direct we're showing
daily file transfer status in this case
how many things have been transferred
over the past time period process
transfer errors drilling up and down
into the reports about those file
transfer activities that have been going
on and down at the bottom we have some
of the detailed instances of those
transfer processes and we're going to
drill down into the lower level
steps or the individual items that were
transferred in this case we're looking
at the names of the files the source
file and some details about that
another example here we'll we see the
actual name of the source and
destination files and some of the IDs
that were available if we need to get to
that level of tracking a history page on
sent and received files by node again
hovering over the columns of data to see
the real time value now we transition to
looking at sterling file gateways
transfer activities that have been
happen so these are files that are being
processed by sterling file gateway and
we have lots of detail on the transfer
process steps that have happened in this
case there are 30-something steps that
have occurred to transfer these files
and route them as appropriate so the
route is now complete some reports about
that file transfer activity producers
and consumers sent received and now
we're looking at some KPI history for
the file sent over the last quarter
showing data points weekly and then
there's another KPI and we're looking at
at the bottom file sent monthly looking
at that for the past year tracking that
an entirely another example here on
looking at how monitor connects
information across different systems
this process touches five different
systems and so monitor is providing us
an end-to-end view of that tracking
across these different systems this is
not a managed process we're just looking
at the process steps and posting real
time data onto the display so using that
we can understand how far along the
processes achieve completion and if
there's any issues along the way
covers of course we're tracking data for
the reporting that we might need to see
about what else has happened we'll log
on here to the mobile application that's
available with Business Monitor and look
at how the KPI is appear on an iPhone
this is a bar chart rendering of a KPI
chart and so you see the actual value in
black the target line is the vertical
white line here's a user selecting the
KPIs that they want to view these are
the model KPIs and can make these
selections as an authorized user a
different visual rendering of the some
of the same KPIs that we're looking at
here the actual value is also shown as
well as shown on the needle all the
ranges of course match everything on the
regular browser now we're transitioning
over to alerts so we're seeing the
detail of an alert here candidate
rejections these are our hiring process
or above normal now we want to get into
the detail of that take some other
actions we can scroll through the
available actions now I'm going to look
at iPad in this case not just KPIs and
alerts but actually looking at the
entire dashboard in this case we've
formatted the information a little bit
differently based on what we want to see
on the iPad itself at the top we have
instances of the hiring requisitions
that are out and then at the bottom we
have some KPIs I'm filtering this KPI
list by showing the instances of
candidate rejections so here are all
those that met that criteria reports as
seen on the iPad as I'm holding
horizontally and scrolling an entire
iPad screen
same reports that you saw on the
browser-based dashboard down flipping
over vertical and scrolling back up
example of the process diagram view that
we saw in the browser-based dashboard
and looking at the KPIs that were
available about the BPM process running
here's the freeform map diagram that we
used earlier and then an entirely
another dashboard view seen vertically
and horizontally on the iPad so some
different options there and then back to
the original last thing we want to show
is uploading some data to Watson
analytics out of our instance view and
the first idea here is to let Watson
explore the data and then create some
exploration to use without doing
anything it looks at the instance data
and gives us some interesting facts and
so it picks out things like the top user
ID by the item quantity based on the
data that we've uploaded looks at some
of those relationships and shows us
things that it thinks might be important
and so we can use these as reference in
creating some different views of the
data that we maybe weren't aware of or
maybe some relationships that we might
want to highlight so this is one of the
views we're going to create a new
exploration clicking new here and then
we're going to use the ability of Watson
analytics to type in the question using
just some words that we know we're in
the data and then it will look and
reformat that question and give us some
choices that make sense based on the
actual names of the fields that we have
uploaded so it's refined our query and
we're going to select one of these so
there's the order total amount over
month by category I'm going to change
this err
into a bar is some of the dynamic things
that you can do just from the
browser-based view of this uploaded data
exclude the July column make some of the
choices and the charting options down
here change this over to an area chart
again click on July exclude that data I
want to see this instead of as an
absolute I want to see this as a stacked
percentage chart so there's the view of
that I'm going to use that as one of my
new explorations now we'll create
another one use the same sort of
technique we get to refined query and
choose one of these item quantity by
user ID and then we have this diagram
that shows us a visual reference based
on the quantities and the user IDs and
we're excluding a couple of these just
to see how it shifts around the view of
the data and we can dynamically shift
the ranges on either end to see what
that does to the resulting output that
we get so we're trimming the top and the
lower ends of the data so another option
there so we're going to switch over and
look at predictive relationships within
the data and again without us doing
anything Watson has analyzed this and
found some interesting targets with some
predictors that were found among the
data that we uploaded so this is looking
at relationships in the data
and it allows us to choose a single or
multiple fields to do this comparison
and then shows us some visuals that
gives us indications of how strong the
relationship is so what influences the
item number what influences the total
amount of the order what influences the
type of product that is ordered what
other fields and what the predictive
strength of those is so here user ID
drives the item type predictive strength
and so on so this will help you discover
some relationships that you might not
otherwise understand from your data and
do it without any heavy lifting so this
was exported from the instance view
right within monitor this concludes the
quick demo